speaking to reporters at the White House
yesterday Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin and economic advisor Gary cone
made it clear that the blueprint is
heavy on to be determined when we have
an agreement we will release the details
and go through with all the good I mean
a tax cut we will let you know these
specific details at the appropriate
moment and there's lots and lots of
details that will going into how that
will pay for itself we will get back to
you with definitive answers on all these
details we are going to move this as
fast as we can and when we have an
agreement we will release the details
and go through secretary minuchin is
with us from the Treasury Department
good morning mr. secretary
good morning it's great to be here with
you thank you great to have you here as
you mentioned this would be historic tax
cuts estimated to cost the American
taxpayer seven trillion dollars over a
decade so when will you tell us how
you'll pay for it well let me first say
this is about the most sweeping biggest
tax cuts and sweeping tax reform in
history and the president is focused on
creating economic growth this is all
about economic growth and American jobs
and that's what the president is
committed to in regards to the pay-fors
I don't know how people could estimate
the costs since we haven't released all
the details but this is going to be paid
for by economic growth and by a
reduction of many many deductions and
special interests why put it out now
mr. secretary without all the details I
think the American public wanted to hear
about it and you know this is something
we've been talking about since the
campaign mr. secretary the question is
what kind of economic growth do you have
to have in order to pay for the tax cuts
the massive tax cuts you're recommending
well we feel confident that we can get
to at least 3% economic growth on a
sustained basis when and that's
something we've said and that's
something that we're confident with and
the American economy has been held back
and this is about unleashing economic
growth it's a combination of the tax
plan it's the combination of regulatory
relief and it's the combination of our
trade principles so and those three are
where
going to create economic growth that's
been held back in this country the
Republican Party is famous for being
against debt and deficits the president
less so what impact is it going to have
on deficits over a 10-year period
well again Charlie I think the president
is very concerned that the debt has
grown from ten to twenty trillion
dollars under the last administration
and that's something we're very
conscious of and as we go through the
details of the plan we'll be comfortable
that we can pay for most of the plan and
that's something we'll be looking at
when we report the ten-year numbers so
what are you gonna do about the American
corporations that have a lot of cash or
not cash so much but a lot of earnings
stowed away in places around the world
and not bringing it back because of
taxes well Charlie it's not a surprise
that people have left trillions of
dollars offshore given the complexity of
our system and the way it works and we
spoken to hundreds of business
executives we're going to have a
one-time tax for repatriation and we
expect that we'll get trillions of
dollars back on shore and that will be
invested in American capital and
American jobs and that's what this is
all about it will create more jobs how
so this is about creating jobs because
many surveys show that seventy percent
or more of the tax burden is borne by
the American worker and this is about
putting money back in the American
workers pocket and this is about
investing more money and plant and
equipment to build American plants and
create American jobs but the secretary
as you know a lot of the reports a lot
of the reporting on this says this is a
lot of tax cuts for the rich and if that
is portrayed as such you'll have a tough
time in Congress well charlie is as I've
said before the president's objective is
about Tax Simplification
and we will be lowering the rate on the
high end
in return for eliminating almost all
deductions we're committed to keeping
charitable deductions in mortgage
interest but everything else is on the
table and this is about Tax
Simplification it's also about creating
economic growth and having people invest
and you have the Republicans in Congress
on board we do we've had we've had lots
of discussions with the leadership and
in the House and Senate we've been
meeting weekly I think the good news is
conceptually we all agree on the plan
and we're committed to work out the
details together secretary minuchin good
to have you this morning thank you so
much thank you very much pleasure